in this our final feature about for
honor we are going to concentrate on the
Vikings after being out fought by the
Knights many moons ago they returned to
the sea but now centuries later the
Vikings are here to annihilate all
samurai and nights let's have a look at
their four character classes and they
executions too first up for the Vikings
are the Raiders who are the epitome of
Viking culture fighting with a
two-handed battle axe and animal pelts
armor the Raiders are the perfect SATA
class as they have ranged attacks and an
unblockable chain attack they have
strong huge with versatile and have a
huge damage output expect to see their
acts embedded in all enemies although it
can be a little difficult retrieving an
axe from a human skull the warlord is a
defensive class which has a short sword
and a shield don't be fooled by the
shield which is also a weapon in the
right hand the wall argues everything
they can including kicking punching and
even head-butting once again they are
more than happy to remove an opponent's
head if the situation calls for it
the berserker is an incredibly skilled
for extremely difficult class to use
they utilize dual axes and flail about
seemingly randomly that will explain the
name anywhere put their ability to learn
multiple blows and change attack is a
force to be reckoned with and yet just
in case you're wondering they can take
your head clean off with just one of
those actually finally the Valkyries are
the Viking jack of all trade these
Warriors are excellent to take down and
use a spear and shield in both defense
and attack the spear keeps enemies at
bay and the shield is deliberately small
to allow for quick movement which can
change your battle in an instant both
male and female variants are
devastatingly efficient and can take on
heavy and light enemies simultaneously
so we've now looked to all three
factions in Ubisoft for honor are you
planning to buy this one or are you a
bit skeptical please let me know your
thoughts below i'm adam from playstation
grenade please do as a favor and drop us
a line I can even think about
subscribing I'll see you on the
battlefield with my samurai brothers and
sisters Vikings night you're going down